what's up guys it's mkbhd well it looks
like the folks over at razer took my
previous video regarding fat desktop
replacements very seriously and went
hard to work pretty much immediately now
but seriously they recently unveiled
what they call the thinnest and lightest
true gaming laptop ever created and it
looks pretty damn sweet too this is the
razer blade and the blade i have to say
is appropriately named coming in with
these absolutely monster specs at just
.88 inches thick one of the most
important features of the laptop is the
dual core 2.8 gigahertz intel core i7
processor with turbo boost and a base of
8 gigs of ram and an nvidia graphics
card with 2 gigs of built-in video ram
with enough power to run the latest and
most intensive games so that's all the
boring stuff but what's really most
impressive is the form factor now don't
get me wrong it still falls into the
heavy category at just under seven
pounds but how many laptops do you see
with this kind of power you know i'm you
know what i'm just gonna say it this is
the 17-inch macbook pro on steroids it's
built very similar but with some extras
like the specialized high resolution lcd
screen on the right hand side if you're
one of those people who loves the form
factor of the macbook pro but you need
that fatty alienware specs then this is
the sweet spot this is going to appeal
to you but but but but there is one more
thing it starts at 2800 bucks the specs
for the price they match you know don't
get me wrong but you won't be finding a
mid-range version for this beast at a
friendly price this is an all-out no
compromises machine and i like that
hopefully i can get my hands on one to
review i'm already a fan but that's all
i got can you think of a better dream
laptop than this if you can i'd love to
hear it seriously major props to you if
you can find one either way mkbhd
signing out
peace
you